was the explanation you got on 70
reported did report as
well yeah the explanation was 70
reported
yes and did they need to announce that
if if both um players report two people
can't
report I don't want to talk about it all
right
I explain everything pregame to a
t okay I did
that 70 reported 58 didn't or 68 didn't
we threw it to 68 that was the
explanation okay um can you just explain
the you know the mentality to go for two
there at the end obviously you wanted to
keep the game in your hand and and try
to win it I told the offense that we
were we were going down 141 left we're
going to go down and score and then
going to go for two and finish this game
out I told him that and so that's what
we were
doing and um being backed up that didn't
change anything when you get backed up
to theeven back up where to the seven
instead of the two from the two-point
play did you think it all we were going
for
win